un changement d'heure qui a posé deux
difficiles problèmes d'horaires à la
sncf comme jean-paul flory a pu le
constater cette nuit à 1h du matin heure
d'été c'est à dire à minuit heure
d'hiver les trains qui sont partis ils
sont partis alors à l'heure d'été les
trains sont partis à l'heure de tela et
pour les jeux pour les grandes lignes à
leurs divers jeux l'auriverde ordis est
pour quand ces derniers par ordis est
donc avec une heure de retard
les autres partent avec une heure
d'avancé celui quand on part avec une
heure de retard je ne comprends pas très
bien
voici ses leurs valeurs leurs divers car
vous n'avez plus d'heures de référence
la a6 et de référencement
c'est là qu'elle l'heure d'hiver où
l'heure d'été à l'heure d'hiver l'heure
d'hiver pour le camp les autres comme il
ya ces grèves
il n'y a pas de train pour aude a peur
donc ça ne pose pas de problème pour
l'instant alors pourtant pour le train
de candide qu'il est parti avec honneur
de 21 ans il est parti et où il va
partir avec une heure deux frères ne va
partir avec une heure de retard à 0 17
heures de retard sur leur nuque et non
une heure d'avancé
valence
une histoire à la raymond devos presque
enfin j'espère que malgré tout ce
cheminot dont la solide assurance du
départ a fini par ce trouble et j'espère
que ce cheminot a réussi à rentrer chez
lui par le bon train à la bonne heure
[Musique]